there's something in the mist and there
were a few things going on behind the
scenes too this is what you might not
know about Frank darabon's impressively
upsetting sci-fi flick
early in his career Frank Darabont was
known as a screenwriter he and his
writing partner Chuck Russell co-wrote
the screenplays for a Nightmare on Elm
Street 3 Dream Warriors and the 1988
remake of The Blob darabot also wrote
The Fly 2 some episodes of Tales from
the Crypt and the young Indiana Jones
Chronicles as well as Kenneth brana's
retelling of Frankenstein titled Mary
Shelley's Frankenstein obviously he's
long had an interest in genre films
Horror in particular while working on
Dream Warriors darabon thought it would
be a good idea to have a project he
could work on as a director he was torn
between two Stephen King stories until
he finally came to a decision one
fateful night the Shawshank Redemption
was almost certainly the correct Choice
as it was nominated for seven Oscars and
changed the trajectory of derebon's
Hollywood career for the better soon he
was working on The Green Mile and the
Majestic after those more optimistic
movies it may have seemed strange to
audiences only familiar with his glossy
feel-good films that he would then
direct something dripping with as much
blood and despair as the Mist
the Mist begins in a rather quiet way
poster artist David Drayton is hard at
work until a storm outside cuts the
power and draws his family's attention
it's pretty bad out there then a tree
crashes through the window destroying
David's hard work the next day the
Drayton spot a strange Mist forming over
the water and head to the local
supermarket for supplies during their
trip that spooky Mist rolls into town
and traps everyone inside the store it's
a gradual build up to the big reveal
that something terrifying is lurking in
the mist and it really keeps the tension
mounting but that wasn't always how the
film opened during the audio commentary
for the film Frank Darabont explained
his original idea for the opening
comparing it to something you might have
seen in the outer limits there's an
accident in a military lab and the Mist
is released into the world to wreak
havoc he thought it was a good idea to
explain to the audience where the Mist
came from however during a Dinner with
Andre broer who plays the skeptical
Brent Norton the actor suggested to
deremont that the laboratory scene might
be worth cutting out after some thought
Darabont was in agreement and he ended
up scrapping any explicit origin scene
for the Mist that sense of ambiguity
makes the film much more unnerving in
his commentary for the Mist Frank
Darabont explained that the exterior of
David drayton's home was filmed outside
of Shreveport Louisiana during the scene
when David and his family wake up to
find their property has been Trashed by
the previous night's storm there's a
whole lot of debris and foliage
scattered about not only did the
filmmakers use all this to create the
Damage Done in the night but they did it
to make the area appear a bit more like
New England with the help of some CGI
mountains the filmmakers managed to
create the impression that the story
like so many of Stephen King's Works
takes place in May This was done so
effectively that even King himself was
fold Darabont recalled when Stephen King
first saw the exterior of David's house
he leaned over to me and said did you
shoot this in Maine if you've seen the
Shawshank Redemption The Green Mile or
even the Majestic then you know that
Frank therabont has a very precise and
cinematic style every camera move feels
intentional and motivated each shot
tells us something about the characters
the Mist on the other hand is a bit more
chaotic the action is happening
everywhere at once and the cameras are
always moving as they try to capture it
that change was intentional part of it
was due to the film's budget and
schedule but some of it was Darabont
deliberately trying something new while
discussing his approach to filming the
Mist on the film's audio commentary
Darabont said I think it's great to on
occasion just shake it up just shake up
everything that you know and try on a
whole different way of doing something
try on a whole different suit of clothes
in order to do this Darabont needed to
be less of in his own words a control
freak he had to loosen up and find
things in the moment as a result cameras
in the Mist whip around the store zoom
into a bit of action then move on to
something else there were even moments
during shooting when camera operators
would turn around and wind up filming
each other all of this went into
creating a realism new to derabot's work
he compared the style to a documentary
and there are moments when it certainly
feels that way Thomas Jane had been in
one Stephen King adaptation prior to the
Mist in 2003 he was part of an
impressive ensemble cast for a less than
impressive big screen version of King
novel dreamcatcher despite the massive
Talent of director Lawrence Kasdan and
co-writer William Goldman the movie
failed to connect when talking to the
losers Club podcast Jane said that he
didn't understand dreamcatcher's script
and he didn't even want to do the movie
at first even though the film didn't
necessarily turn out to his liking Jane
was drawn to it by his appreciation for
Stephen King's stories that's likely why
he accepted Frank darabont's offer to
star in the Mist which proved to be an
exciting development for the director
Darabont had been a fan of Thomas Jane's
work for some time but they never got
the opportunity to work together until
production started on the Mist when
Darabont finished writing the script
Jane was the first actor to read it and
things just snowballed from there
Darabont said of the experience I was
very happy that Thomas Jane wanted to
make this movie in the experience of
working with him was everything I'd
hoped it would be it was really lovely
the cast of the Mist includes some major
Heavy Hitters recognizable faces known
for delivering Great Performances Thomas
Jane of course is the lead of the film
he previously appeared in Boogie Nights
as the effortlessly cool Todd Park and
he played Mickey Mantle in the Billy
Crystal directed 61. Andre broer had
spent years in the hard-hitting drama
series homicide live on the streets
finally Marcia Gay Harden had been in so
much that mentioning her earlier credits
would take all day there were also a few
actors Frank Darabont had worked with in
the past Jeffrey Damon played Dan Miller
the man warning everyone of what's in
the Mist but he'd previously been in
both Shawshank and The Green Mile the
same is true for William Sadler Lori
Holden had previously starred in The
Majestic before doing the mist and
Darabont brought her over to do The
Walking Dead as well there was plenty of
established talent in the film but that
doesn't mean they stole the show there
were a few local hires actors living and
working in the same geographical region
of filming who really brought the house
down one in particular Melissa McBride
who would go on to play Carol in The
Walking Dead lured everyone with her
performance as a mother begging to go
home to her kids according to darabont's
commentary when McBride was done filming
the entire cast and crew applauded even
the big stars among them
if there's one element to the Mist that
doesn't always work it's the CGI the
scene on the loading dock when they open
the door and inadvertently let in a
tentacle is particularly rough it looks
more like a cartoon than a limb of a
living creature occupying the same space
as our human characters at least that is
until they dismember it and the CGI
becomes practical
it's pretty emblematic of the entire
film the old school Practical movie
Magic grounds everything while the more
recent techniques falter for instance
the market that was found for the
exterior was so perfect that its
interior was recreated on a Sound Stage
Frank Darabont also mentioned in the
film's commentary that what we Glimpse
outside the store window is a massive 20
foot by 60 foot digital photograph of
the actual store's exterior area these
days Productions would probably try to
use something like the volume a
technology pioneered for the Mandalorian
that allows filmmakers to film
photorealistic digital backgrounds on
the set with the actors the earthquake
scene was also done practically instead
of artificially shaking the image or
lifting the whole setup on a gimbal the
crew simply shook the shelves shook the
cameras and pulled down the lights
derabond also said that speakers were
brought in to play the sounds of an
actual earthquake the fact that he
didn't tell the actors the sound was
coming meant that their reactions were
more authentic back when movie posters
actually inspired prospective audience
members to see a film artist drew
struzen was King think of any great
movie poster that you've seen and
chances are whatever pops to mind was
painted by strusen Big Trouble in Little
China Blade Runner and the Star Wars
Trilogy special edition are just a few
of his masterpieces he even produced
posters for the Shawshank Redemption and
The Green Mile in the featurette Drew
strusen an appreciation of an artist
derabot gushed about struzen's
contributions to cinema to honor the
iconic artist Frank Darabont decided to
base his main character's own work on
that of struzen when we see David
Drayton adding color to the Rose
hovering beside a gunslinger who
Darabont confirmed on the commentary is
Roland from a fictitious adaptation of
The Dark Tower he's actually working on
an original struzen that was
commissioned for the production not only
that but darabond also pointed out that
David's workstation is fashioned on
strusen's personal studio in the
background we can see posters for
Guillermo del Toro's Pan's Labyrinth and
John Carpenter's The Thing poster
streusen also made in the end darabante
admitted I thought it was just time for
us to acknowledge how much we love
Drew's druzen
the ending of Frank darabont's the Mist
is a real gut punch to say the least the
original Novella was open-ended all we
know is that the characters who survived
are going to continue traveling through
the Mist until they find something
there's no closure For Better or For
Worse the movie on the other hand
delivers a disturbing and deeply
unsettling finale that not everyone in
the audience is going to be okay with
David Drayton Mercy kills his friends
and son only for help to arrive in the
Mist to blow away just seconds later
what inspired this gruesome climax when
talking to fellow screenwriter and
director Mick Garris about the Mist
Darabont explained that he isn't the
same fresh-faced optimistic kid who made
the Shawshank Redemption he opened up
saying the events of the 21st century
have not been to my liking I see the
game being rigged and re-rigged and
re-rigged so many times if we're going
to continue to make the same stupid
mistakes then what the hell value is
there in our species in another
conversation with Stephen King himself
Darabont mentioned that the film's
ending felt natural because King had
written a story about how people break
down and do terrible things under
pressure just to survive in that same
conversation he explained that before
agreeing to make the movie with
Dimension films he needed Studio
executive Bob Weinstein to agree to let
him do the ending because it was
non-negotiable thankfully he got to make
exactly the kind of movie he wanted to
there have been a ton of movies based on
Stephen King's books and short stories
over the years and not all of them are
great king himself doesn't always
approve of the movies based on his work
it's not just The Shining either King
went as far as to sue new line Cinema to
have his name taken off the extremely
Unfaithful adaptation of the lawnmower
man it's not impossible to impress the
king of horror though there are a number
of adaptations that King quite enjoys
King wrote very favorably of the Mist in
an updated edition of his non-fiction
book about horror dance Macabre as he
put it Frank darabont's vision of hell
is completely uncompromising if you want
sweet the Hollywood establishment will
be pleased to serve you if you want
something that feels real come here
darabon could have made a higher budget
film if he'd added a cheerful it's okay
kitties ending but he refused his
integrity and courage shine in every
scene foreign
[Music]